da sind wir thematisch auch schon bei
dem was heute im bundestag ansteht in
der haushaltswoche
nämlich der etat für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz unter anderem und damit sind
wir thematisch von unserem
korrespondenten und reporter im
bundestag jörg schäfer
ja vielen dank stephan kohler einzelplan
09 so heißt das werk das hier ab 9 uhr
diskutiert wird zum ersten mal nach dem
gründerjahr einen neuen titel klima
wirtschaft und klimaschutz das war
bislang noch nicht in einem haushalt
vereinigte und auch schon gar nicht in
einem ressort und wir haben es in diesen
tagen natürlich damit zu tun dass wenn
man über dieses ministerium redet und
über dieses ministerium diskutiert und
über seinen etat spielen natürlich
energie das thema energie
energiesicherheit bezahlbare energie
eine große rolle und dann sind wir auch
schon wieder bei dem thema dieser nacht
und beim koalitionsausschuss der ja um
11 uhr seine ergebnisse bekanntgeben
will wir sind gespannt wie das ganze
ausgegangen ist wir werden das thema
energie und energie sicherheit aber auch
jetzt schon besprechen und ich freue
mich dass bei uns sind heute morgen wie
franziska brantner parlamentarische
staatssekretärin beim bundesminister für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz guten morgen
ihn und alexander dobrindt ist er erster
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unionsfraktion und natürlich auch
vorsitzender der csu landesgruppe auch
einen schönen guten morgen guten morgen
frau brandner was können sie uns schon
sagen zu dem was wir um 11 uhr dann auch
offiziell erfahren zumindest die
richtung natürlich wissen wir die
fraktionsspitzen werden sich die
ergebnisverkündung vorbehalten aber
können sie zumindest eine ahnung geben
in welche richtung es gehen könnte wir
haben ein entlastungspaket für
bürgerinnen und bürger als die
verbraucher und die unternehmen
und das ist glaube ich auch richtig und
gut so die details werden um 11 uhr
vorgestellt bitte verzeihen sie mir dass
ich die jetzt noch nicht nennen kann
aber ich glaube wir sind auf einem guten
weg hier die bedürfnisse zu sehen
zielgerichtete und gute antworten zu
finden womit rechnen sie ja dobrindt da
sind wir schon sagen dass er ein absolut
singulärer vorgang dass ihm gerade in
den haushaltsberatungen das heißt
vorgestern hat der finanzminister den
haushalt eingebracht gestern hat der
bundeskanzlerin haushalt begründet und
heute nacht sind offensichtlich
entscheidung getroffen worden die
erhebliche auswirkungen auf den haushalt
haben uns ist bisher nichts bekannt ein
sehr seltsames vorgehen man könnte auch
sagen eine kloses vorgehen gegenüber dem
deutschen bundestag das hier gehört dass
hier verhandelt wird über einen haushalt
währenddessen die regierung
entscheidungen trifft die vollkommen
unbekannt sind und in diesen
haushaltsdebatten doch keine rolle
spielen können nicht mehr sein
vorbereiten wahrscheinlich wollten sie
das eben auch schon andeuten wird das
natürlich auch noch im parlament
behandelt werden natürlich ist es ein
ergänzungs haushalt der der aktuellen
situation geschuldet ist dass wir in
europa einen krieg haben mit natürlich
auch massiven auswirkungen auf unser
land und es wäre ja verantwortungslos
wenn wir das ignorieren würden die cdu
selber hat ja nach auch entlastungen
gerufen wir haben jetzt ein gutes paket
geschnürt natürlich wird das auch durch
den bundestag gehen als ergänzungs
haushalt das ist ja klar aber wir müssen
in der situation reagieren das ist so
alles andere wäre verantwortungslos
kommen wir mal toll gewesen wenn man vor
einigen tagen eine entscheidung
getroffen wird in der bundesregierung
wir haben die auch angemahnt haben die
entlastungen eingefordert die
energiepreise sind nicht seit gestern
explodiert und gestiegen sondern seien
auch unter der enns und unter hätte man
da hätte man rechtzeitig natürlich
handeln können jetzt sagen sie ein guter
kompromiss wir kennen den kompromiss
nicht sie können auch nicht vorstellen
also wir wissen nicht immer gut ist ich
habe erhebliche zweifel weil wenn der
debatte gestern und vorgestern er
gesehen haben wie unterschiedlich
zwischen den grünen der spd und der fdp
die interessen da verteilt war wir haben
einen vorschlag gemacht wem gesagt
entlastung bei der steuer bei der
energie steuer bei der mehrwertsteuer
wir sind sehr gespannt ob die
bundesregierung diesen maßnahmen
nachkommt zu bewies vorgeschlagen haben
jetzt kommen nämlich meine ganze
erwartungsvoll an ging die inhalte sind
irritiert weil sie gerade auch einfach
schon mal geantwortet haben bevor ich
was gefragt habe aber wir sind noch
nicht zurück im regulären verfahren da
freue ich mich frau brandt ist eine
finanzdebatte dass hier noch nicht um
das ist ein interview
wie sicher ist die energieversorgung im
moment in deutschland die
energieversorgung ist sicher die ist
wirklich gesichert wir haben seit januar
angefangen auch wieder die sogenannten
long term auction für gas zu nutzen das
sind optionen die wir haben
um die gas bestände auch zu erhöhen das
haben wir schon vor dem krieg gemacht
das heißt wir sind da absolut jetzt auf
einem guten weg und richtung herbst und
winter da kennen sie ja da sind wir
intensiv nicht nur international dabei
sondern auch bei uns mit einem paket was
jetzt kommen wird oster paket sommer
paket um bei uns auch effizienzen zu
vergrößern in die erneuerbaren zu gehen
grünen wasserstoff voranzubringen wir
gehen jetzt wirklich in die vollen um
von dieser energieabhängigkeit von
russland auch loszukommen das ist das
gebot der stunde wir sehen dass die
energieabhängigkeit einen sehr hohen
preis hat den können wir uns auf dauer
nicht leisten
und deswegen nutzen wir jetzt wirklich
auch diesen haushalt um noch mal ein
schritt voranzukommen der
parteivorsitzende der csu ihr
parteivorsitzender herr dobrindt ist
anderer ansicht der meint ohne kernkraft
hat er getötet heute wird es kalt und
teuer im nächsten winter als brücke
braucht ist die kernkraft noch für
mindestens drei jahre es muss schluss
sein mit ausstiegen aller art der
energiepreis wird so zur armutsfalle und
zum standort nachteil das wäre reine
grüne ideologie heizen wir demnächst mit
atomenergie
leider verweigert sich das
wirtschaftsministerium einer
ideologiefreien prüfung der kernenergie
und der möglichkeit des weiterlaufen der
kernkraftwerke wir wissen dass 13
prozent des russischen gas in
deutschland verstromt werden das heißt
es wird daraus strom produziert und wenn
man dann auf der anderen seite sieht
dass wir kernenergie abschalten mit der
wir den strom weiter produzieren können
dann sieht man wir schaffen keine
unabhängigkeit von russischen erdgas
sondern wir halten an diesen
abhängigkeiten leider mehr fest als es
notwendig wäre und deswegen ja es ist
zwingend geboten jetzt die prüfungen
noch mal richtig durchzuführen
ideologiefrei durchzuführen die
kernkraftwerke die dieses jahr noch
laufen weiter laufen zu lassen und
möglicherweise auch die im letzten jahr
abgeschaltet worden sind wieder ans netz
gehen zu lassen das wäre zwingend
geboten jetzt als maßnahme um
unabhängiger wert zu werden von den
russischen importen habe ich trotzdem
noch mal eine technische frage die alle
busse die große anteil was er über gas
angeht wird tatsächlich für fürs heizen
verwendet geht in den gasheizungen
beispielsweise rein da kommen sie mit
der atomkraft nicht voran das stehen was
können sie tauschen das stimmt das geht
aber auch nur schritt für schritt wir
haben das immer deutlich gesagt ist ein
sofortiges abschalten des zu führen der
energie aus russland halten wir für
nicht möglich es kann uns allerdings das
ist ja offen von der anderen seite
drohen wir sehen ja dass putin auch
weitere maßnahmen gerade wenn es um das
bezahlen geht jetzt mit rubel einsetzt
um es schwieriger zu machen und deswegen
ist die bundesregierung ja auch
aufgefordert und dabei maßnahmen zu
ergreifen wie man diese unabhängigkeit
am schluss und darstellen kann ob
einzelne elemente daraus dann von
unserer seite gegriffen werden können
ist nach wie vor offen aber es braucht
elemente um unabhängiger zu werden die
kernenergie wäre eines dieser also wir
halten die in dieser pauschalität ist es
offensichtlich nicht umzusetzen wie es
von markus söder getwittert wurde frau
brandner
mit atomkraft kann man nicht die
gasheizungen ersetzen es ist einfach
nicht möglich das ist aber dass herr
söder gesagt hat das ist offensichtlich
falsch wir haben das sehr intensiv
geprüft und das ergebnis gekommen dass
es die probleme die wir haben nicht löst
aber extrem hohe kosten verursachen
würde weil wenn sie weiterlaufen
brauchen die atomkraftwerke eine neue
sicherheitsüberprüfung und ich bin mir
sicher dass auch sie sie nicht ohne eine
neue sicherheits überprüfung
weiterlaufen lassen würden und meine
ideen für aline ohne groß die gefahr
aber trotzdem geht's auch unsere
sicherheit
erreichen es geht darum dass wir schauen
was sind unsere genauen probleme die
haben wir beim heizen und wie gehen wir
damit um wir haben die übrigens auch in
der industrie dort hilft es auch nicht
dass heißt wir haben konkrete probleme
mit der gar mit dem gas deswegen können
wir auch nicht sofort auf null gehen mit
russischem gas und wir suchen nach
antworten
müssen haben die antworten und im
verhältnis stehen zu den kosten die sie
dann auch erfordern und bei der
atomkraft sehen wir dass mit blick auf
die sicherheit sehr sehr hohe
zusätzliche investitionen nötig wären
die sind wirklich sehr groß und ich bin
nicht bereit die sicherheit unserer
bevölkerung durch ungesicherte
atomkraftwerke zu riskieren das würden
sie in haus und eine
sicherheitsüberprüfung und die werden
wir deswegen
auf andere wege gehen sie haben gesagt
die verstromung das wird über kohle
stattfinden das ist auch in unserem
grünen interesse kann man sagen ist
genauso schwierig für uns aber es ist
der effizientere und bessere weg und
wenn sie mir erlauben ich finde es
wichtig dass wir in deutschland auch
darüber nachdenken wo wir energie
einsparen können wir haben von der
internationalen energieagentur zwischen
klare empfehlung bekommen welche wege
aller helfen beim sowohl im privaten
aber auch im verkehr als auch in der
industrie da müssen wir jetzt auch an
diese effizienzen zu geben dafür gut
übrigens auch noch extra gelder das ist
teil des entlastung wäre in der tat eine
meiner nächsten fragen gewesen warum so
wenig über energiesparen und
energieeffizienz in diesen tagen
gesprochen und diskutiert wird aber sie
haben verschiedene einwürfe gemacht eben
als verbrannter geantwortet hat deswegen
wichtige in die gelegenheit geben die
auch noch noch zu formulieren eigentlich
habe mich zurückgehalten weil man kann
nicht auf der einen seite diese sehr
ernstzunehmende bedrohung betrachten
wovon nicht davon ausgehen dass die
bundesregierung das auch wirklich tut
und erkennt was der möglicherweise auf
uns zukommt und dann elemente nur weil
sie halt ideologisch unbequemen
ja
so muss beide besser zu machen
die kernenergie ist halt nun mal ein
element mit dem man die gas zufuhr aus
russland reduzieren könnte dass er jetzt
nicht alle probleme sagt ja auch keiner
aber es ist ein element wir brauchen
unterschiedlichste bausteine natürlich
ja die kohleverstromung auch die kohle
muss woanders eingekauft werden dass er
will ja auch das muss woanders ein
gehabt die wir haben ja gesehen wie der
bundeswirtschaftsminister einen
hofknicks vor den kataris gemacht hat um
jetzt lng gas einzukaufen
alles das ist notwendig stück für stück
um dafür dann ein ersatz für den
russischen energie zu kriegen aber ein
plan muss
immer noch größere abhängigkeit von
russland gebracht hat weil sie das team
2 und diese projekte vorangebracht habe
wir sind also dass wirksamer weil es uns
gefällt sondern weil sie die
erneuerbaren gebremst haben weil sie
noch weiter uns in abhängigkeit von
russland gebracht haben wir haben diese
abhängigkeit geerbt weil sie 16 jahre
lang im falschen polizisten sehr naiv
vor wohl einst gerhard schröder ist bei
der spd und nicht bei der uni
kennzeichen immerhin die
friedensdividende die putin zerstört hat
er nicht nur den frieden zerstört er hat
die friedensdividende zerstört wir alle
sind davon ausgegangen dass der handel
mit russland den frieden sichert weil er
wohlstand auch malen sei dann schaut die
davon nicht ausgegangen sind und es gab
auch lose reihe die gesagt haben
das grundprinzip frieden durch handel
war gemeingut und ist auch nicht falsch
natürlich ist es richtig dass der
gemeinsame wohlstand den frieden sicher
dass das grundprinzip des aufbaus von
europa dass putin jetzt das gegenteil
tut ist eine ganz bittere erkenntnis auf
die wir entsprechend reagieren müssen
aber jetzt so zu tun als ob in allen
fragen der energieversorgung bis zur
verteidigung die grünen diejenigen
gewesen werden die es ja immer schon
wussten dass wir bei der nato bleiben
müssen dass wir aufrüstung betreiben
müssen dass wir klare teilhabe haben
müssen all das finde ich ehrlich
reichlich reichlich abhängig jetzt
müssen wir mal ein bisschen gucken dass
es nicht ein bisschen zu durcheinander
geb ich will mal weil sie von grüner
ideologie gesprochen haben ich habe
einen artikel gefunden aus einer
süddeutschen zeitung von 2011 an steht
alexander dobrindt plant den großen wurf
um ein sichtbares zeichen für die
umstellung auf erneuerbare energien zu
setzen verlangt der csu generalsekretär
dass die bundesregierung gelder
umschichten die maximale beschleunigung
des energie umbaus sei dringend
notwendig da könnte man natürlich frank
da haben sie erkenntnisse gehabt die wir
heute dringlich brauchen warum ist ihnen
derzeit nicht so viel passiert dass wir
schon auf der sicheren seite sind dass
der satz ist ja damals richtig wollte
auch nach wie vor richtig und genau das
ist ja auch passiert wir haben doch
einen maximalen ausbau auch gerade an
erneuerbaren energien ermöglicht bayern
ist ja vorreiter im bereich der
wasserkraft im bereich der bio immer bio
gas im bereich der geothermie
so das ist ja alles auch da und wird ja
auch weiter verstärkt von da wir bauen
die offshore windenergie mit maximaler
geschwindigkeit aus und den leitungsbau
das heißt ja erneuerbaren energien
zwingend notwendig wir können uns ja
auch mal gern drüber unterhalten warum
die planungen teilweise so schwierig
sind und wer vor ort dann oft auch genau
die gegnerschaft anführt wenn es um
ausbeute netto bringen wenn sich hier
behaupten wollen wir hätten den
maximalen ausbeute in den letzten jahren
gehabt das ist doch wirklich einfach
eine lüge würde enorme beschleunigung
von mir meine arbeit den maximal aus
barbies gerade gesagt uns einfach falsch
den haben wir leider nicht gehabt in
deutschland wählen wir den gehabt hätten
wäre es heute besser dann werden wir in
einer besseren situation des reit- und
organisiert wenn sie meine leute
erneuerbare energien gesetz nicht
entsprechend war ganz ganz am ende dann
haben sie ja lange nicht gar nicht
gelüftet sie haben bei den
windkraftausbau
angeschaut haben weil der windkraft sehr
gedeckelt sie machen überhaupt nichts
wenn die leitungen blockiert die wir
dringend brauchen von nord nach süd
lässt so war familien obdachlos
geworden weil ihre ausschreibung ist
hoffentlich ermöglicht haben dass nach
baden württemberg jemand kommt und
deswegen wissen natürlich ist es war
herr dobrindt wir ändern ist ja jetzt
gerade zum glück was und dann werden wir
sehen wie wir schneller vorankommen so
jetzt mal ganz zum schluss aber nur
knapp eine minute noch haben hat der
russische präsident herr dobrindt hat so
können auch schon mal angesprochen will
sich sein gas jetzt in rubel bezahlen
lassen was bedeutet das für die haltung
wir beziehen auch in näherer zukunft
erstmal weiter das gas was wir über die
verträge eigentlich jetzt bekommen
sollen in den verträgen ist klar
geregelt dass in euro oder dollar
gezahlt wird deswegen wäre das auch ein
rechtsbruch russischer seite wenn sie
diesen vertrag an der stelle brechen
würden wir stimmen uns als europäer ab
weil es natürlich nicht sinn macht dass
wir jetzt national darauf reagieren
sondern im konzert der europäischen
partner das wird jetzt am gipfel auch
besprochen aber erstmal muss man wieder
klar halten hier wird ein vertrag
gebrochen noch
in kürzester kürze embargo oder nicht
gegen russland das ist brutaler di
figaro beiden vertrag berichte oder
nicht er verfolgt ein ziel und das ziel
ist natürlich die eigene währung zu
stabilisieren
das wird für uns möglicherweise
schwerste folgen haben die noch nicht
abzusehen sind wer keine rubel hat aber
mit rubel bezahlen muss der muss sich
google besorgen und das total geht ist
total offen und wir müssen alles
unternehmen um diesen krieg zu beenden
und deswegen ja es wird auch immer
wieder weitere sanktionen geben aber es
geht nicht darum dass wir jetzt die
energie abschalten können sondern ich
muss auf sicht eine unabhängigkeit vom
russischen gas und energie energiezufuhr
geben das hat was wir machen auf ihren
dächern oberen vielen ein verbrannter
wir können noch eine viertelstunde
weiter doch gerne da gehst du nicht
bereit wer mal sehen wie es weitergeht
es gibt ein kohleausstieg haben sich ja
schon ein bisschen bewegt zumindest
gehört sich dass ein klein wenig so an
was zumindest als zumindest ist es nicht
komplett verworfen
wir müssen aufhören für heute morgen
weil sie müssen auch ein sie müssen auch
ganz fix reingehen jetzt dobrindt danke
frau brandner